so i threw a pull-up um i need my space
what does it mean
i really just left two options doesn't
mean anything just support her and give
her space four percent of you said that
84 percent of you basically said that
she's exploring other options and see
what these guys say andrew said depends
on context if you just met her and she
needs her space then fine just treat her
as a plate and occasionally bang low
effort if you're already in a long-term
relationship with her and she says this
you should get out there and never talk
to her again i would agree with that for
the most part
uh moose says it's womanized for i want
to break up see sometimes women are a
little too chicken to break up with you
or they're afraid of the fallout or
maybe there's some cray-cray going on or
maybe she's not sure about the dude that
she's monkey branching too so it's like
you know she wants to
you know test drive you know the one car
today and then test drive the other car
tomorrow maybe there's another one on
the lot that she likes as well that
she's checking out too or a few on the
lot that she's checking out but you get
the point you know she doesn't you know
it's like having one foot in the old
life and one foot in the new life and
that's what that generally means it's
not usually guys that say i need a break
it's usually coming from her
and it generally translates to i want to
break up i just don't know how to
execute on it
um
here's one from sofa on policy says i
need more space doesn't always mean i'm
a garden tool it can also mean you sympt
i would agree with that as well
you know like if you've been simping for
you've uh you know like if you treat her
like a celebrity she's gonna treat you
like a fan at some point through the
beta tization through a thousand
concessions which is again something i
do talk about in my book in a few
different parts you will you will come
to understand why these things happen
um just you know just get your head
around it it's not it's not rocket
science it is what it is
um let me see here there's a door don't
let it hit you on the way out okay
here's another one from spark he says
uh it means one of two things either
she's testing the relationship in which
case
let her leave and if she's comfort
testing you she will instantly attract
the same in the other scenarios she can
do better and explores more options with
men or wants to get ran through in which
case lever never looked back
listen
there is no cut and dry one solid answer
let's fit in a
box and sell it to the world um
it's a moving target but again for the
most part
if you're in a long-term relationship
but and i'm not talking about you just
dating her for a month or something like
that she says i need space you should be
spinning other plates at that point to
which you don't really care
fine take your space i don't give a
and go do your thing when just you know
pull up your phone and you know text the
next one uh but if you're like a couple
years into something like that or you're
dating or living with her i mean there's
all these guys that i've talked to over
the years they you know they've got all
these like well you know we're just
going to take a break or a trial break
or a trial separation or whatever they
want to call it a break or my space
insert whatever reason
it's not good especially if she's
bringing it up it's always a precursor
to something going
more sideways the best thing that you
can do
and
i went down the rabbit hole of of like
googling you know um to see what
articles that were out there or what
videos were out there and for the most
part it's garbage it's it's it's going
to plug you back into lies it's going to
mislead you
uh it's certainly deceptive and it's
mostly you know
i mean how can i put it i mean it's
really just a hallmark card you know
when you come across most of the stuff
out there
i'm going to tell you the cold hard
truth this is how you deal with it
she says hey i need my space cool i'll
see you later
all right you want to ask her you know
what's up why do you need the space you
know at least get in the dialogue in
fact i would encourage it but at after
that point in your head
whether or not you've broken up or she
thinks she's broken up or she's decided
to leave you or to
try out some other dude or tyrone or
kevin from sales or whatever else is
going on in her life in your own head at
that point you have to mentally break up
with her you have to fro
from the get-go from that starting point
basically think to yourself it's over
that's it
you can't control any part of the
universe the only part of the universe
you can control is yourself and how you
perceive certain dynamics and
interactions you can't control other
people you can't control what they think
of you you can't control how they feel
for you you can't control if they're
gonna love you or whatever it is you
know that ties into that narrative you
can't control any of those things but
what you can control is your own
thoughts and your own life and where
you're gonna go
start going to the gym if you're not
going to the gym stop doing dorky things
maybe one of the like i'll be honest
with you a lot of the times when women
need their space it's a lot of the times
because guys get
they get a little too comfortable they
stop chasing excellence
and they spend more time doing something
that's not that productive in their
lives
women are hypergamous they want to get
up in the morning and look at you and
say this guy's the best that i can do i
can't do any better that guy kevin from
sales i don't care he ain't nothing
compared to
rob you know we'll use rob here as the
example
when you when you're on the decline when
she sees you as less of a man than when
she met you six months ago six years ago
whatever it was when she sees you as
less of a guy
then that's generally when she starts
leaning into areas like i need my space
we need a break we need a trial
separation blah blah blah blah blah you
get the idea
there's another comment here from abele
says i was engaged back in august and
the wedding was in october and i heard
this from her after i gave her space she
texted me back saying we need to talk
shocking right
we met to talk all of about 20 minutes
and she broke the engagement off
okay
you know what dude she did you a favor
abel i know that it probably didn't feel
good at the time hopefully in hindsight
you can look back at this and say to
yourself dodged a bullet on that one you
know actually dude in the comments says
she's a merciful woman that actually did
you a big favor i know it sucks now but
it was much better yeah
exactly
another dude greg here says did you ask
her for his name
and that's generally what happened you
know i need my space i gotta explore
myself uh andrew says it's unfortunately
fell for the manipulation you should
read your book yes absolutely he should
absolutely uh it means renegotiation of
terms and conditions and you cannot
negotiate genuine burning desire it has
to come naturally
uh facts indifference is always the best
response to manipulation sabotage
tactics such as i need space your ace in
the hole will always be apathy she's one
of a million not one in a million very
well said my friend very well said
um
jaren here says
with those i need space lines i always
say something like great i was thinking
the same thing i'm glad we're on the
same page your tone usually changes at
which point you get to reject her
another way to handle it you get the
idea guys okay
you know a lot of guys get super hung up
on it and you know believe it or not
this dude rob that was on the response
uh and so he he was basically you know
the respondent on the ghosting equation
because there's always like you know the
person that leaves and that there's a
levy and there's a lever so this guy's
you know the respondent because he ended
up ghosting her that time
he he was in a good bargaining position
until she was like you know can we just
just see past this you can just come
over can you cover my place tonight
please please please i love you i don't
want anybody else but you
and you know what's going to happen he's
going to go over like the pleb that he
is she's gonna do the gymnastics hanging
from the chandelier with the monkey
craziness going on and what he's gonna
do then he's gonna be like i love you so
much i can't wait to spend the holidays
with our families together and blah blah
blah blah
only in the back of his head he's going
to know the entire time that he was not
her first choice
he was the
second third choice whatever he might
have been
clearly wasn't the first i mean she was
out fishing for a new dude on a dating
app found him while she's still seeing
the old dude trying to hash it out it
doesn't work out
he catches on to her game tells her to
pound sand actually doesn't even tell
her to pounce down here's the right
thing he just ghosts her ass she gets
upset about it throws a hissy fist calls
in a radio station and puts him on the
spot on the air and then he folds anyway
she sounded really desperate like she
can't do any better right now
boom
enter chad that guy chad always shows up
doesn't he it's either chad
chad the pool boy kevin from sales steve
from accounting
he's out there fellas
that's why you got to be on your grind
man put yourself first chase excellence
not women don't be a simp don't do any
of these silly things like you know
become her second or third choice
the most important thing aside from
frame and my estimation is
making sure that you're her first choice
making sure that she's got genuine
burning desire for julie says i didn't
get that i need my space instead i got
the i need to go find myself that
basically means the same thing except
for you change i need to go find
myself with whatever his name is
okay
at that point again like i said at that
point when when this happens you've
you've gone pretty far down the
it's ending rabbit hole and in your head
at that point you have to think to
yourself okay it's over it's done you
know that's it and then mentally prepare
yourself
for that exit
do what you got to do for some guys it's
going to be up the time they spend in
the gym hang out with the bros maybe
they play more pickup hockey
maybe they book a flight and they go
down to some resort or some caribbean
island they just go to pound town for a
week you know you can do whatever it is
that you want that gets you distracted
from the nonsense of i need my space
are there times when she really does
need her space
i don't know there's a family member
that's really sick
i mean but like realistically if you're
in an ltr with her why wouldn't you be
included in that you know scenario
uh why wouldn't she use you for support
i mean i
i can't think of one
i just can't think of what um
big project at work you know there's a
big deal closing i i mean listen if you
date some of these you know professional
boss girl women
lawyers uh some of these professionals
they might have deadlines leading up to
a big contract or agreement or something
that needs to sign and they're gonna
need 24 36 48 hours or
a long
like period of time of work where they
need to get this project done over a
couple of days
maybe
okay but the
completely ghosting in this example
where she's not even responding to his
texts or phone calls you know he
explicitly said why did you disappear
for days
right that's not cool you know
it is what it is
you